hello everyone and welcome back to the
1909 match between Frank James Marshall
and josé raúl capablanca I will say we
already seen a couple of games in this
match Capablanca is four points three
points in the lead the result is four to
one and since its first to eight wins
it's quite a quite a handicap Marshall
has to overcome to get back into this
match here he has the white pieces
against Capablanca this is I don't know
if I mentioned game 11 and it's really
an insane game when you see this game it
will you you will feel like one one guy
is the superhero other guy is the
villain and you will really want you
know something to happen it's it's
really a thematic game and Marshall is
attacking like a madman capablanca is
defending like a madman you're you're
definitely in for a treat so without
further ado I will not be mentioning
anymore that capablanca is still without
any opening theory knowledge as you guys
are starting to make fun of that in the
comments but he does say so in his book
so it's a I mean it's not like I'm
making it up but okay D for Marshall
opens would be for we have d5 and C for
the Queen's Gambit is on the board east
six knife to c3 and Knight to f6 and we
have Bishop to g5 Bishop to e7
we have III and now capablanca once
again goes for his knife to e4 move as
he overheard a last fare plated once
against Frank Marshall and okay but rope
captures only seven Queen captures on e7
and now again
capablanca always was in favor of white
capturing on d5 first were before
starting anything else here Marshall
goes for Bishop to d3 and Capablanca
says that this just gives the black to
2/3 of a game Knight captures on c3 we
have B captures on c3 and now D captures
on c4 opening up at this diagonal for
blacks light squared Bishop Bishop
captures on c4 and now b6 preparing to
fianchetto
the light square bishop that's the b7
Queen to f3 attacking the rook on a8
first kappa blanka defense we have c6
and not nice to eat you preparing to
castle the shop to b7 now c5 is
definitely an idea
we have castles kappa blanka also
castles and now a four Capablanca says
that this a four might be a bit of a
waste of time as you will not be able to
push this point any further any time
soon and white doesn't really care if
black pushes b5 so maybe maybe be nice
to a four by immediately starting an
attack against the black King would have
been better now but okay couple uncle
goes c5 definitely a move you want to
play to free or light school shopping b7
Queen to g3 and now nice to see six
cover bunker continues the development
of his pieces Knight to f4 white is now
star starting an attack against the
black king but it's capablanca mentions
it will not be all that easy to create
this as there are not and not made very
many pieces in front of the black King
but okay we have rook 8 to see it
we have push it back to a two you don't
want to allow this Bishop to stay and c4
unguarded while the rook is eyeing it
push up to a two and now rook F to d8
with this move Capablanca says that he's
ready to win the a four point and it's
interesting how he does it
we look to f1 by Brooke Fe one by
Marshall
now comes Knight to a5 a very nice move
making room for the bishop on c6 and now
the bishop from c6 will attack the pawn
on a4 and also the knight on e5 is
preparing c4 to lock in this
LightSquared bishop on a two wheel rook
a to d1 by marshal and now comes a
bishop to c6 attacking the e4 pawn and
there's no there's really no way to
defend the e4 pawn so Queen to g4 is
played by marshals preparing an attack
against the black King and creating all
sorts of tricks it's interesting
Capablanca says if a d5 it's an
interesting move but he was he was
confident and black will be able to fend
off the attack and then just keep the
extra pawn let's say e cap ich after
some d5 after Knight captures on d5 now
Queen to a fate getting out of the
attack and also keeping the Queen on f8
to help out with the defense now Queen
to h4 shifting the Queen over to attack
the h7 square now comes roof to d7 and
now
Bush of the b1 threatening checkmate as
you can see here with f5 defending and
now the knight on d5 is hanging you do
have to protect it let's say e 4 but now
comes Luke 2:8 and after c4 giving
further protection to the knight now
couple Anka will capture the e4 pawn
fend off the attack and then well keep
his extra pawn start pushing his a pawn
and trade pieces and so on and so on
and marshall agrees with him he doesn't
go for this tricky move he goes for
Queen to g4 and it's a it's a very
tricky move here if Capablanca
immediately rushes to grab the pawn but
he captures an a4 then you get Knight
captures on e6 and this will be winning
for marshal F captures Bishop captures
with check tink has to move and now you
simply grab the rock and c8 of course
you cannot capture as the Queen is also
protecting the bishop
so after queen g4 first couple Blanca
closes the diagonal as planned c4 and
now most likely it was best the shifted
the bishop over to be one to start the
further that you know and make the
attack happen just a little bit faster
but here at Marshall went for d5 he's
going for complications okay Bishop
character Sunday for you're not allowed
to capture here as the bishop is already
attacking the rook on d1 so first look
to d2 and now II five Capablanca says
that this is a an okay move but it's not
it's not the best of most he wasn't very
happy about this move maybe Jesus would
have been better you're still like a
white still cannot capture here as the
rook on D 2 is undefended
so here black would simply prepare f5 e
5 and it would have a much more solid
position here capablanca immediately
plays d5 with nice to h5 now marshall
threatens checkmate g6 and now it's if
you go Knight back to g3 you get Bishop
back to d7 attacking the Queen and after
the Queen moves f5 black consolidates
keeps the extra pawn and already it's
black who's on the attack so here
instead of moving back the night we have
d6 a very nice move of course the pawn
cannot capture the night as the pawn is
pinned but it's a very nice move you
cannot capture the pawn as the rook on
CH would be now hanging Queen
uncie eight would be the frit so after
d6 we have Queen to e6 couple Blanca
snatch the pawn so now he offers a queen
trade Queen to g5 now and going for
Knight to f6 but also in some lines
preparing some very nasty ideas as
you'll see King to h8 capablanca freeze
the g8 square for his rook so now the
pond isn't pin you can capture on h5 but
also if some sort of emitting attack
happens the rope can also shoot back and
to help out with the defense nice to f6
we have rook captures and d6 and now
rook captures on d6 Queen captures on d6
and now Bishop the b1 shifting the
bishop now to help out with the attack
Capablanca brings back the night into
the game nice to see six and here comes
the up to f5 an excellent move by
marshal threatening the rook and c8 and
if the bishop is captured then you see
how white wins here Queen h6 there is no
defense against Queen H so in checkmate
black would have to give up the Queen
and it is all over
so after Bishop a5 will rip to d8 backup
of lanka and here marshal played h4 and
cup of lanka mentions in his book this
was the moment where
marshal could have could have saved the
game he had he had a better move but
we're gonna get back to that here he
played h4 he started in an attack
against of course the black king he
wants to push h5 break up into position
and Capablanca immediately takes his
opportunity and brings the knight into
the game 97 comes with an attack on the
bishop and now we have nicely for
attacking the Queen here Queen to c7 and
now Queen to f6 with check King to g8
and now Bishop to e6 again trying some
going for some complications but it
doesn't help capablanca captures the
bishop we have Queen captures any six
with check King to f8 and now comes
Knight to g5 threatening checkmate and
we have Knight the g8 the Queen now also
guards DF 7 square F for marshal wants
the break opened DF file so he can go
rook to f1 check and continue the attack
rook to e8 attacking the Queen and this
move capablanca says that while the
he should have you know continued to
defend the excellently and here this
move is a blunder but capablanca
position is so much better that it
doesn't matter that he makes this well
we can say blunder because the Marshall
place F captures on e5 opening up the F
file for free and now you cannot capture
the Queen because knife captures would
check and if the King moves now nightcap
person c7 and now it's actually Marshall
was up in material so after F captures
on e5 will rook to e7 making room for
the King to escape you still cannot
capture the Queen of course rook to
everyone check team to g7 now going for
that
and now h5 still the queen is off-limits
as the king is still in range of the
fork
we have Bishop back to EA to bringing
the bishop back into into the defense
and now Marshall again continues his
ferocious attack we had h6
a wonderful move if King captures on h6
is possible but if we forgot Blanco
plays Knight captures then he loses
control of the f6 square and then it's
Queen f6 check King Jade and Queen FA to
checkmate
so still a lot of poison to the position
King to h8 was played by capablanca and
now comes Queen to d6 offering the Queen
trade and again Marshall is just playing
this position beautifully if Queen
captures pawn captures then white is
winning because after you block the pawn
rook to f8 wins the bishop there's no
square left for the bishop so an
excellent idea and even if rope captures
you don't even have to capture the
bishop I mean you can but now still nice
to have seventh thread of checkmate is
here really in just an all-out winning
position so after Queen this the Queen
36 we have Queen to c5 Capablanca now
offers the Queen trade but on c5 also
threatens at the capture on e3 while
defending the rook on e7 and now Queen
to d4 Marshall now wants to trade Queens
and default unn unn double his epon and
also fix his pawn structure in the
center
rook captures on e5 and now comes Queen
to d7
again Marshall with the with the
beautiful ideas Queen g7 is the threat
of checkmate if capture
Queen the knight of seven is mating one
of course the pawn is controlling g7
square after Queen d7 we have looked
east seven block in mate and g7 and now
comes Luke to f7 after playing this
Marshall Marshall is hoping for rook
captures Queen and after Luke captures
Bishop captures of course Knight seven
is checkmate
but as Capablanca already spotted the
mate it is very unlikely that he will
fall for it this time so here in cold
blood kappa blanka played Bishop capture
son d7 and it was in this position that
Frank James Marshall resigned the game
unmoved 43 why did he resign well he's
you know queenless and there's nothing
nothing else to do nothing works you
cannot make here because the rope is
controlling h7 so that obviously doesn't
work it's just a lost position but
before I forget I did mention that F at
this moment when Bishop Delphi was play
we said of course you cannot capture the
bishop because of Queen h6 here rook the
d8 was played getting the rook out of
harm's way and here Marshall played h4
but there is one move and it's such an
insane move it's you we might say to
move all moves as it's if I didn't tell
you this move was here there's no way
any anyone what spotted cover banca
mentions it in his book so he obviously
found it but it's it's just amazing and
it's really a weird move that uses the
whole board to you know make things work
for white but it's just really awesome
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the move that allowed
Marshall to to survive this game I'll
give you a couple of seconds but you
know feel free to pause the video and
take for as long as you want for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an incredible
player as this move is I don't know well
without further ado afro if you just
wanna enjoy the show Bishop to d7 and
it's uh it's really like I said it's a
weird move but black has no moves now
I mean what do you play here really of
course you cannot move the Queen if you
move the Queen then you get the Queen to
h6 this is winning the Queen has to
constantly keep an eye on the knight on
f6 if you play rook captures thinking
okay I'll grab two pieces for for the
rook
then again Queen to h6 threatening
checkmate and it doesn't matter if black
captures here then comes Queen to have
faith checkmate
this is really really wild another idea
after Bishop to d7 you cannot bring the
knight into the game if you try to bring
the knight into the game then you lose
the bishop on a4 so that obviously
doesn't work and if you try to shift the
rook let's say you try to give up the
rook via roof to g8 simply to control g7
or to play rook g7 still doesn't work
white just ignores you and now White has
an excellent position I mean look at
blacks position now white just plays h4
black is still without a move you can
lay rook back to d8 White was still
ignore you h5 and let's say you try bush
of the c2 you try to activate the bishop
it doesn't work the bishop always has to
keep an eye on the knight on c6 so you
cannot move it if the bishop moves
immediately Bishop captures on c6 is
played this is the real threat of Bishop
to d7 Queen has to capture the bishop
and now comes Knight captures on h7 as
there is no protection of the rook on d8
so here blacks position falls apart and
or you captured and Queen captures broke
and then white is just winning but yeah
this Bishop to d7 move such such a
beautiful move it's it's been it's been
a very long time since I've seen a move
like this it's just I mean wow
everything like this Bishop to d7
paralyzes all of blacks pieces and of
course a couple of ones only spotted the
move I believe after the game but since
he immediately played 97 after the move
perhaps he saw it even during the game
why they are really really are crazy
crazy game that but but really shows how
what a ferocious player Frank Marshall
was about yeah without further ado
that's enough wowing for one video I
would like to thank Luis Alejo Salazar
Dennis
boots of David Wilkins Russell Oh
and joseph hines for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos er thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
with some more content from the
Capablanca vs. Marshall match as you can
see it's quite quite a match so thank
you all and I'll see you soon